oh and ginny dear congratulations on
making gryffindor
your father and i are so proud hands up
everyone who thought ginny weasley
didn't get the attention she deserved in
the harry potter movies
for those who saw the films junie may
not appear as significant to character
as she was in the books
today we're going to examine why ginny
felt like a minor character
you never know what you'll find up here
[Music]
for anyone who hasn't read all the books
or seen all the movies
approach with caution this video does
contain spoilers
you hear that we must be getting close
[Music]
let's start with the books readers of
the series were treated to a
strong and layered character whereas the
movies left the youngest weasley as a
bit of an afterthought
ginny is introduced in the harry potter
series as a very young and inexperienced
girl
she comes off as quite soft-spoken and
nervous
especially around harry for whom she's
always had an affinity
as the youngest of seven siblings and
the only girl in her family besides her
mother
it was quite easy for ginny to be
forgotten about and cast aside
while these were her circumstances it
certainly wasn't the case
as ginny was a far stronger character
than she was given credit for
especially in the movies well done
everyone great
great work in the books readers see a
smart
feisty independent powerful and
inspiring woman
come on jenny we'll get you a seat hurry
during harry potter and the chamber of
secrets ginny becomes of huge
significance as she is under the
influence of tom riddle
not that she knew what she was doing she
was shall we say in a kind of trance
while viewers of the film see a love
struck doe-eyed and lost girl
let's consider the fact that she was
literally being controlled by a horcrux
during her first year at hogwarts
the damage a silly little book can do
especially
in the hands of a silly little girl
talk about diving in off the deep end
harry began to notice her more in the
midst of this and paid her some
attention
but we aren't sure he really took in how
strong this young girl was
let's take a minute to note that ginny
went through an extremely traumatic
hardship
and against all odds she came out of it
stoically
but also with a fire in her eyes it was
me riddle made me later in the books
she unexpectedly became a quidditch star
going so far as to win the house cup
while she took over being the seeker
since harry was stuck in detention
this detail was sort of glossed over in
the films but it actually adds a lot to
her character
as the youngest and only girl in her
family she used to steal her brother's
broomsticks to practice and became
incredibly skilled at what her brothers
called
a boy sport she was a girl that was all
about defying the odds and not letting
circumstances hold her down
while this may seem minor it's a detail
that speaks a lot to her strength and
resilience
this like many other instances where
ginny was a vital part of the story
was skipped over and the movies focused
more on harry's reaction and involvement
since the movies are named after him and
the point is to follow his story
it makes sense but it is a shame that
jenny is mainly seen as his love
interest
instead of the determined charismatic
woman that she is
don't be so me
it started out as a schoolgirl crush and
ended in marriage and kids
we're glad this turned out like a happy
ever after but how did ginny go from a
nervous young girl to the woman harry
wanted to spend his life with
first let's consider the fact that ginny
was always truly honest
she may have been a bit shy but she was
always truthful about how she felt
can't you trust me remember those
awkward singing cards
once ginny saw that harry had eyes for
cho chang
she didn't let it get her down it's just
learning all this
makes me wonder whether he'd known it
our girl moved on checked out her
options and played the field
she didn't allow the judgment about
dating around that she got from ron to
affect her
and snogging that happens to be my
sister so
never apologetic she was true to herself
in the way that she lived remember when
we said she was resilient
not only did she open herself up to
other romantic prospects
but she was also respectful of harry's
feelings for cho and never tried to
meddle
mature spunky and clever how harry
didn't fall for her earlier we're not
quite sure
perhaps the film's choices about ginny's
character can explain that
take my hand once harry finally
recognized how incredible ginny was
they got together but that realization
was covered so quickly in the films that
audiences barely had time to absorb it
what the movies didn't show was how
ginny and harry were equals
and the fact that the boy who lived
needed ginny just as much as she wanted
him
ginny was the one harry confided in the
one who he could laugh and relax with
since it's obvious that ginny was much
much more than just a random love
interest for harry to date temporarily
ah it's weasley come in come in
it's important to note the way she
behaved after harry broke up with her
there was no grudge held and jenny
understood that at the time
there were just more important things
going on even though they weren't a
couple for a while
the littlest weasley showed her maturity
and continued to support harry
and her fellow cohorts at hogwarts
fiercely and
loyally harry what happens if umbridge
does find that
who cares a true friend there is
definitely a lot to cover in the movies
we get it cutting down these books to
two hours is hard
which is probably why they skipped a lot
of the special moments that were written
but we wish they had since it would have
made ginny and harry's union near the
end of the series
that much more powerful and exciting she
and harry wound up together because they
were partners and needed each other
not just because she was crazy about him
remember dumbledore's army yeah it was
our girl jenny that came up with that
name
she neville and luna are also the ones
that kept it going and supported all the
students who were at hogwarts while
harry ron and hermione were away hunting
horcruxes
in the early days of dumbledore's army
genie was also
mastering extremely difficult spells
with ease and proved herself to be
a very powerful witch
how about that reducto curse let's not
even get
started on her stunning patronus charm
the movies only showed us a glimpse of
this
and left the continuation of
dumbledore's army as an afterthought
which is too bad
speaking of ginny being an amazing witch
remember that she was
also an integral part of the battle at
the ministry of
what was magic reason for the connection
between you
and countless others this powerful witch
tried to steal the sword of gryffindor
from snape's office
talk about risk these acts of bravery
were vital to the harry potter stories
and unfortunately many folks who only
saw the films wouldn't know just how
vital
since they didn't make the cut in the
movies since it was the harry potter
series
people who watch the films were mostly
shown the relationship harry had with
others
and how various events affected him
readers of the series will recognize
that the books delved further into
ginny's relationship and interactions
with others
hello ladies love potions eh
yeah they really do work one
relationship of note is that of hermione
and ginny
the two of them were there for each
other and actually quite close
even when they had their disagreements
they met each other with compassion and
sophisticated thinking
the movies mainly focused on hermione as
the strong female character
and since there were a lot of characters
and a lot of stories to cover
it's understandable however it is
unfortunate that audiences didn't get to
see
the dynamic power of these two strong
independent female role models we've
established that ginny was so much more
than the films gave her credit for
so let's recap who she really was she
was the daughter of arthur and molly
weasley
she was the youngest and only girl of
seven siblings
she was an honorable gryffindor a
powerful witch
a loyal friend a fiery force to be
reckoned with
and not just because of the color of her
hair she was ginny weasley
while the movies didn't serve justice to
the character we know in our hearts that
she was far more than just a love
interest
how do you feel about the way ginny was
portrayed in the films would you want to
see a film with ginny as the main focus
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below don't forget to subscribe
and head over to our channel to check
out the rest of our potterhead content
you